okay welcome to the python dashboarding
shootout and showdown
uh i'm james bednar i'm the director of
technical services at anaconda and
basically what that means is that i run
a bunch of consulting projects with
different external
organizations so that's my actual job
but more relevant today is that i'm a
founding member of two groups that
me and several colleagues set up called
holobiz and pi biz and these are groups
not controlled by anaconda they're
independent of anaconda
and the main hat that i'm going to be
wearing today is as pipe is and kaibiz
is an organization that is just trying
to promote python data visualization of
all types of any any library any
dashboarding tool as we talked about
today
anything that helps people get their
work done in
in python so for the for the large part
i'm going to have my pi biz hat on but i
have to acknowledge that i'm also a
member of holobiz
and holovis is one of the tools today
that we'll talk about uh called panel is
a holobiz tool and so uh just be aware
of my biases and background and we'll
talk about that more in a minute um but
from here and unless i'm saying
otherwise i'm here speaking in terms of
pi biz presenting the python biz
ecosystem and organizing this workshop
to help people learn more about python
biz tools and
uh dashboarding tools in this case
so this particular workshop is about
high-level
python dashboarding tools and we had a
little discussion in slack is what is
dashboarding should we call this
dashboarding another another
term that's thrown around is web app
another is analytics app sometimes ml
app or data app
um
basically all of these tools have in
common they'll let you write some python
and then uh put something that someone
can
is not you can view in a web browser
and this particular workshop is focused
on high level tools there are much lower
level tools for instance panel is built
on top of bokeh and you can completely
use bokeh to build web apps directly but
this workshop is not about bokeh it's
about the higher level tools
you can also build
such tools with flask or past api or you
can build entire websites with like
shopping carts if you want with django
this talk this workshop is also not
about that
it's about people who've been able to do
something in python and are ready to
share it with someone usually something
involving data
it's also not about developing apps
directly in html and javascript
obviously you can always do that but
this is a workshop for python
programmers
so you'll be hearing from four different
tools today and they're listed here in
chronological order and i'll just try to
give you a little bit of background
about these tools and where they come
from
um
first off you'll hear from uh
here about plotly dash that was released
in 2017 which is very popular here these
numbers are a combination of the conda
and tip downloads over the previous
month
um
[Music]
next you'll hear from panel again that's
uh that started in anaconda it's not run
by anaconda it's uh it's run by this
separate organization so in fact the
person will be defending it or
presenting it is not from anaconda
that was released uh later it's it looks
like only one year but i think it's more
like two years almost two years
um
and then uh you'll hear from uh voila uh
uh sponsored by but i don't know if you
would say it's controlled by you'll
probably hear more about that uh uh
quant stack came around a little bit
later not much um and then streamlet uh
is a company called streamlit and uh
don't pay too much attention to these
download numbers for instance voila is
primarily a server that you combine with
other things and a lot of panel users
for instance don't necessarily use a
server so the fraction of those that use
the server might be similar to voila so
just take with a grain of salt and
really just try to remember these are
all popular packages a lot of people are
using them these are not some obscure
side package you'll be hearing from the
leaders in the field
and who will you be hearing from
so for plotly uh that'll be the first
talk um
they're from nicholas christian uh vp of
productapotlet.com
uh panel uh panel is primarily a work
with my colleague
phillip rudiger it's his brainchild and
he uh stewards it uh he couldn't be here
at the last minute for travel reasons um
but uh the number two contributor panel
is here uh mark scott matson he um is
the lead data science scientist
developer at urstead although he can
pronounce that better than i can
um while i'll be represented by sylvain
corley who is the founder and ceo of
quantstac
and streamlet by adrian triu al the
co-founder of streaml
and it's kind of worth thinking about
right before we dive into it
just the
to put everything out in the open about
who's presenting these tools who's
pushing them who stands to benefit from
them
and
try to balance between their python open
source and but they you want to have a
tool that's well funded and you really
you want to somehow connect money to
developers and get problem solved and
they each have different models and i
don't know how much people talk about
those different models
but for instance panel is primarily
funded by outside clients of anaconda
who
pay for money to give money down to
conduct for certain things to be added
to the ecosystem
plotly
i guess makes money on their server
products uh streamlet is new they'll
probably tell you how they make money
and so on
uh while uh constructing to get outside
contracts as well
so everybody can talk about about that
aspect of that and hopefully everyone
will be open and honest and uh and
uh
clear about
what drives development in the library
and how you can go forward with that
library if you choose to
all right so i'm ready to step back and
i'm just going to listen to these
presentations and then after the end of
the presentation everybody's got 15
minutes then we'll come back for uh q a
and discussion and comparison between
libraries and so if anyone has any uh
questions like that or discussion topics
please put it on the slack channel and
then we'll revisit those at the or visit
those at the end of all the talks
so over to nicholas
all right hello everyone i'm going to
start my timer here um thanks for for
inviting me uh jim my name is nicholas
christian uh i am head of data
visualization at plotley i i'm also a vp
of product um and i'm excited to sort of
talk a little bit about dash here today
so
um jim went over some of this already uh
we call dash an analytical app framework
uh here at potli um pretty easy to
install pip install dash we're
downloaded some number of times a month
um dash
as a framework was initiated and is
supported by plotley uh partly the
company we also make plotly the python
library um
and uh
dash is an mit licensed uh open source
uh library it is the open core of the
dash enterprise product that partly
sells so pili has an open core uh
business model we we develop dash and we
sell dash enterprise and there are two
sort of separate things um they're just
one clarification there's no sort of
free version and expensive version of
dash it's all the same dash i'll talk a
tiny bit about our commercial offering
at the end just for clarification
purposes
um
i wanted to kick off with uh with a
little live demo um of sort of what uh
what it's like to to work with the dash
app so hopefully
this is big enough to fit um
so here is basically code wise what a
dash app
minimally i guess is
you've got a couple of imports you
create the app there are two little
pieces here there is a layout
and optionally some callbacks and then
you run the app so let me kind of run
this app
and we can see what it looks like
if i run this app this is this is the
output so the layout is a little tree
here
of
of components so i've got an input
component and an h1 component
and the callbacks are a little bit like
excel formulas they uh they map inputs
to outputs and so in this particular
case i'm mapping
the children of the out component uh
there's a function that that drives this
based on the value of the in component
and what what that transformation is is
just it just says hello and so here i
can say hello you know pi data global
uh nice to meet you
so basically what happens is every time
i type a character into this text field
that python function is called
that's what dash gives you uh you don't
have to know any javascript um to make
this work uh you don't have to write any
backend uh you know rest methods or
anything like that you don't have to
wrangle any json you kind of lay out
what your app is going to look like here
in this layout and you wire it up with
callbacks
okay so far so good
if you run this app with debug equals
true you have this little blue puck at
the bottom here this is your developer
tools it tells you that your server is
up you don't have any errors there's a
little error panel
and you have a little uh interactive
graph here of your callbacks so here
okay yes this is basically what i've got
i've got a very simple in-out
relationship
now i'm going to switch over to a
slightly fancier app
this one is called fancy i might have to
scroll a tiny bit so this is about you
know 40 lines of python it's got roughly
the same structure i'm going to just
call it the layout here
has an h1
a drop down and then two graphs and then
i have two callbacks the first callback
binds the drop down to the graph and the
second one
binds the drop down and the first graph
to the second so
let me just kind of run this and show
what that can look like to make it a
little clearer
so
the the app has reloaded and in this
particular case i've got a drop down a
scatter plot and a map
and the the callback graph
for this i've been a little bit confused
but i can sort of tease it out um and
i've got my
this isn't worth spending time on um but
i've got my my graph and so i can change
the the year that i'm presenting data
for and you can see everything updates
and i can make a selection over here
and that selection is reflected on the
graph below so this is kind of an
example of what you can do
with the dash app the callbacks i hid
them just because the
visual noise but they're not very long
the first one basically just displays
the scatter plot filtered by the
drop-down and the second one displays a
map filtered by the selection of the
previous one
so mostly what i wanted to show here is
that you can put lots of different
things in your in your layout
and anything can be an input anything
can be an output
so that's what a dash app sort of
minimally has to be um and i'm going to
switch back to my deck for a second here
to to just kind of highlight you know
there's the layout which is basically a
tree of dash components that have props
and then callbacks any component can be
an input or an output
i also wanted to give you a sense of
what a dash app can be
by showing you dash apps sort of some
some in the wild some of our demos so
dash apps can be dashboards sort of
typical
you know dashboard types presentations
you zoom in things filter
this is using dask and data shader for
sort of large data processing
so this is a typical kind of dashboard
style app where you're making selections
and querying a static data set uh you
can have this nice interactive graph
dash apps can be printable reports this
is uh
an example from our gallery
this is a multi-page app so each page of
this printable report has its own
dedicated url
and you can have a full view where you
can kind of scroll through you can hit
command p
on a mac and this thing will print
control p on windows
so a dash app can can power a printable
report
a dash app can be a slide deck
you can have components that look like
that looks like slides and you can sort
of connect these things to live data
sources if you want
here i'm just going to play like two
seconds of this youtube video without
sound a dash app can be a very
sophisticated workflow tool with dozens
of dropdowns and this sort of like
multiple step thing where you've got you
know select a file and check the
messages and multifile plots so it can
be a multi-step uh you know wizard type
thing that produces dozens of charts
sends emails
whatever you want so there's some some
interesting bioinformatics stuff going
on here
dash apps can be scientific
communication tools so this is a
beautiful
application that was released alongside
a paper in nature and we're increasingly
seeing scientists basically like
publishing papers and then and then
publishing dash apps alongside to give
folks access to the data or algorithms
that their papers are about
so this is entire thing here is a dash
app including the user guide which is
pretty cool
uh and then the last thing is dash apps
can be kind of fun and engaging this is
like a retirement planner um you know
it's like you uh you say you want to
retire at 59 you hit go
and this thing will generate a nice
attractive little report for you um
at least i did earlier yeah so you've
got your sort of expected wealth over
time various different things these are
all sort of data driven based on the the
calculator that was above and you've got
some extra charts that you can make
so that's what a dash app can be
and i know i'm kind of doing the thing
where it's like draw two circles and
then draw the rest of the owl but you
have to kind of believe me that um all
of these apps that i showed you are
basically built out of these these two
primitives you've got a tree of dash
components with props and you've got
callbacks that wire them up um so
hopefully that can be a little bit
inspiring in terms of what can be um
i'll have a link to this deck at the
very end here
so to give you a sense of who uses dash
uh you know we we have direct reports
and direct communications with with sort
of python first timers who are really
excited they've picked up python and ash
and bit of sn pi data all at once uh and
they're really excited and some some
python old hands um who dash is for uh
data scientists scientists engineers
analysts uh people working in finance
pharma energy utilities government sport
media tech um there's not really you
know a vertical that the dash is sort of
specifically for uh and and we're really
seeing folks using dash and sort of all
of the different departments of of these
organizations so
if you see yourself on this deck you
know dash is for you if you don't i'm
sorry i missed you um but uh but uh but
you know it really is intended to be a
general purpose
so let's get let's get down to brass
stacks uh dash is back-end architecture
so dash is built using flask um under
the hood uh and therefore you can deploy
a dash app uh anywhere you can deploy a
flask app it deploys on heroku it
deploys on any cloud host we have you
know users and customers that have
deployed a dash app pretty much anywhere
you can think of
dash's back end has a totally stateless
http
type of pattern so each of the callbacks
that are written are sort of pure
functional callbacks they can be
executed by any worker if you have a
load balancer in front of a dash app you
can have dozens of workers spread across
you know 10 or 12
machines if you want and you can just do
a round robin kind of distribution it's
trivial to scale horizontally
dynamically you can just add workers or
remove them um
[Music]
to to a kind of a cluster of running
dash apps or you can just you know run a
single dash app with g unicorn and use
three or four processes or something
like that to handle load so this is sort
of one of the biggest strengths of dash
is this stateless architecture
uh and uh i guess it's implicit in the
the little app that i showed you but
there's no limit to the library
libraries that you can use you know you
can use search you can use
tensorflow whatever it is you want you
have full access to the python code the
promise that dash makes is that whatever
the user does in the browser we'll call
the python function that you have asked
to be called
and whatever that python function does
is up to you connect to databases call
apis run things um so long as it's a
kind of a pure functional operation um
dash dash will work
dash's front-end architecture is built
on top of react we published a cute
little article that says you know dashes
react for python that could be some
people um so so dash is built using
react and the reason we said that dash's
react for python is that any react
component can be turned into a dash
component we have a a system called the
dash component boilerplate you kind of
annotate your react component you know
turn the crank and out comes a dash
component um so that tree that layout uh
that layout tree
can contain anything that can be a react
component so out of the box we have um
you know every html element has been
wrapped we have a
bundle of components called the dash
core components which includes sort of
inputs and drop downs and sliders and
graphs which are powered by plotly
the graphing library
and sliders and so on so there's a bunch
of first party components that come with
dash
first party being being plotly i guess
the people who made it
and alongside plotly maintains some
other libraries such as cytoscape.js
dash component for network
visualizations dac for we call it data
acquisition but it's basically a bunch
of widgets that look like physical
widgets
we have dash bio which is a set of
bioinformatics focused components
we have wrapped vtk working with the
developers of vtk for high performance
scientific visualization and there are
also third-party components so the
community has really stepped up and
there's a there's a company maintaining
a bootstrap
set of components for for styling your
app um some people you know really like
leaflet as opposed to the the plotly
powered maps
so they built um leaflets set of
components so it's pretty easy to to
make a react component into a dash
component and there's lots of people
doing that
and not sharing the results many of our
customers will have custom components um
in in the apps that they're building
the dash ecosystem is also pretty broad
um you know i'm here at pi data i love
python we have a back end for for python
um but the the front end can be
connected to
you know any kind of back end and so we
have a back end for r we have a back end
for julia we have back end for f sharp
so this is a you know a broader
ecosystem and folks who are using other
languages are able to leverage all the
same set of front-end components uh from
their language of choice and we have
made it such that the
the various back-ends are sort of you
know mutually compatible in terms of
design so you can kind of move back and
forth and reuse some of the principles
that you uh you have learned
uh dash supports any graphing library in
principle uh any of the graphing
libraries that exist in the python
ecosystem can be wrapped in a react
component and therefore a dash component
i've done it
most of our users use plotly in practice
definitely you know this is what we use
in our documentation uh the dash team
and the plotly team back in back in the
day when you know i wasn't sitting in my
spare bedroom all the time we used to
sit a few meters from each other um
so so definitely
you know plotly's is the one that's best
documented but there's not any technical
limitation for any other graphing
libraries
for developing uh dash applications in
jupiter we have a a look-alike package
called jupiter dash which you sort of
drop in instead of dash
and you can build applications in
jupyter although i will say most people
do build um do build their dash apps in
something like the s code or or pycharm
um
a dash app when you deploy it you know
runs from a python file um and uh and
you know this is this we call these apps
they really are intended to be sort of
like software engineering and deployed
and testable
um and then finally a big part of the
dash ecosystem uh is our dash enterprise
product so dash enterprise basically
adds to dash open source um we add you
know deployment tooling some
infrastructure some additional
components and support from plotley so
there is nothing limited we have not
crippled open source uh dash open source
is a is a powerful you know
heavily adopted tool every single one of
our enterprise customers uses dash open
source every day it is the core of dash
enterprise it is supported by plotley
our business model you know we sell
software we sell dash enterprise and we
sell support for dash enterprise and we
reinvest an enormous amount of that
money into uh into the open source
ecosystem be that the dash core the
plotly graphing library any of the
components uh answering questions on the
forum etc
so that's a little bit about the
dashboard
ecosystem uh
we are almost over you may have one
minute
one minute that's all i need
so to get started uh just visit
dash.plotline.com
if you want to see more cool apps uh
with source available go to
gallery we have a very active community
forum at community.plotli.com
where people my favorite part of this is
the show and tell where people post the
apps that i then come and show it talks
like this
if you want access to this slide deck so
you can click on these links yourself go
to bit.li
pdg pi data global pdg hyphen dash um
that is the link to this and i am i'm
really excited to be part of this panel
uh hear what the other what the other
folks have to say and then and then have
a nice positive discussion and all in my
last 15 seconds say thanks to jim and
say that i'm very proud to be part of a
community where where we do this kind of
thing and and have these fun sessions
and
sort of exchange like this so so thanks
to the other panelists as well
thank you nicholas really great
presentation
so my name is mark and i'm here to give
an introduction to panel and thanks for
taking the time
so um
what you see here is actually a panel
app and that's what i'll be doing for my
talk i'll be using a panel app so you
can find actually this app at my github
site markzware messen awesome panel
introduction
and you really should check it out
because you can find all the code and
you can also open the app right now on
binder and also find the code on binder
so back to the presentation so a little
bit about me
so i'm here actually
i'm not working for a company called
panel or something like that or for
anaconda i'm working for a company
called ester
i'm not representing ursula here
in this talk i'm representing my myself
and my passion which is data apps
but
just to tell you a little bit about my
employer
so erst is ranked the most sustainable
energy company in the world three years
running
it's the leading offshore wind
company and it's also
becoming a renewable energy major as we
speak
check it out
um a little bit more about me you can
check out my site
data models analytics so there's a
little bit on me about me you can see me
here i'm working for traders this is not
traders and us this is just a general
picture but i'm working for traders
every day and it's a fast-paced
environment with a lot of data a lot of
visualizations and a lot of things
changing all the time we make a lot of
small apps all the time
some of these apps stay around some are
thrown away the day after
so
in order to support use cases like that
and also
to support
medium-sized company where we have
engineers we have analysts we have
scientists we have data scientists we
have devops we have machine learning
experts
i was looking for a data app framework i
wanted something where it's really easy
to use the application in twin
in a lot of situations so both for data
exploration
i'm really into data exploration not
only making charts but i really want to
make them interactive with small widgets
like sliders or drop-downs or something
like that so i can really
filter in and focus and discuss with
myself and my colleagues
also in trend in the sense that it
should reach production it should be
really easy to get to production so
getting things out as a report a static
report or an interactive web app
and it's python we're talking about here
so
i wanted something that could bridge
that as well i wanted something where
you can easily build a lot of apps like
a multi-page app so what you see is
actually a multi-page app it's pretty
easy i just have 10 python files each is
a
python application a panel application
and then you can start it up and maybe
we should actually take a look
how does
something like an application look so
here we have a simple application
it's actually seabone
and you can just change the color of the
plot it's not really advanced this might
be like the output from a machine
learning model instead and you want to
play around with some of the arguments
to the function
but the key thing is i can use cbone
here because i was also looking for
something where i can work together with
my colleagues in trend some people
prefer or need matplotlib for their use
cases
some people
need or preferred bulky some plotly some
people prefer each art for example
because they are nice like transitions
when you change the plot right it looks
really fresh and modern
and i wanted something where you can
sort of take
python's database end-to-end and grab
layer collaborate on and and this panel
provides as well i want something and
you'll see that where you can really
build like streaming streaming
applications
i wanted something where beginners in
python could work for example in
notebooks because that's often where
they start out so you can build
pen labs or do exploratory data analysis
with panel in notebooks and we'll see
that
i also because i'm an old grumpy coder
you could say i want to work in vs code
and i want to be efficient there and i
have a lot of colleagues working in
pycharm and i want a framework that
supports all these use cases
so let's get back to the introduction
so
no matter
where you are especially like if you're
a domain expert somehow then the panel
is something something for you
i run two sites so i run
awesomepanel.org and
awesomestreamlit.org so i think you
should check them out as well
um so one of the promises and something
i'm really pretty interested is in is
that this really works with the tools
you know and love so
we can check some of this out pythons
this
so as you can see here you might see
your favorite plotting library here
let's take a take a look and see okay
this is celtir
this is pokey this is
tectile it takes a little bit to load
but it's really nice
e charts
pretty nice
volume
and so on
and if you are out there if you
are working with the repository i made
and open the app you can find all the
code for each example here you can just
drop that in and run it
so we also support bloodley of course
plot nine
pi day
and so on
this template that you see here
it's also pretty nice it's not something
you have to develop because i want my
applications to look smooth
right i'm going to communicate with
colleagues or stakeholders or customers
and it just needs to to look nice so it
should be really easy to make nicer
applications
because
i need to communicate and sell
my things and that's also one thing i
would like to say today actually that no
matter which
data app framework is your favorite i
believe you should look into data app
frameworks it's a superpower for you and
your team to be able to master a data
app framework because then you can
really explore your data and you can
really showcase it to your colleagues
and stakeholders again so you can get
out there with your data and your models
and get feedback and iterate that's
really important
one of the promises that's also pretty
important for me is actually that we're
bridging here so we can actually use
ipad widgets i've just put in a few here
for example you can use ipad leaflet if
you're into ipad leaflet that's a really
advanced and complex library really
really really powerful but here put in
ipad sheets and you can see here we have
a
slider and yeah it reacts to this
and we have ipi widgets as well
and yeah we can use them
one of the things i was also looking for
was like highly reactive
applications i wanted
i wanted to be able to react to events
from my plots like
hover and click and stuff like that so
a lot of these plotting libraries like
call of use or plotly or echarts
provides that and i can use that with
panel that's pretty amazing
so for example here we are looking at
holoviews and if you have not heard of
holoviews it's a part of holovis which
is an ecosystem of data visualization
tools
of which panel is a member and all these
tools integrate really nicely with panel
so here you can see we have nice
interactivity here we can
yeah
make our own data our own chart and we
have
reactivity bindings here
similarly
here we have a3 plot what is hv plot you
might ask but this is a data
visualization library that should make
it really easy for you to make
interactive parts so what's the easiest
way and most well-known way that's the
pandas plotting api so pandas.plot or
dataframe.plot and it's actually the
same hp plot is appendest.plot api so we
have a data frame called sprint and then
we just instead of writing dot plot we
write dot hvplot and then we get a nice
highland plot
one of the
true gems or unique things of the
holovis ecosystem something that's
unique in the python data ecosystem is
data sheet
and what problem does datasheet solve it
solves the problem of big data right we
get more and more data
like millions of rows or billions of
rows where we need to apply
desk or
cuda or
something like that in the background to
work with them but we also want to
visualize it and that's what data shader
enables us to do it can really like
visualize
terabytes of data at cern or places like
that
and just to to tell you that
i really believe that that's a really
stronghold of panel the strong
integration with datasheeter is that for
example
rapids they built a
big data visualization
framework on top of panel and data
shader so
rabbits built this cox filter
on top of panel and bokeh and dl and all
stuff and if you look at it here you can
see this is actually panel apps
highly interactive on big amounts of
data and i think they're pretty nice
then there is prem and param is
powerful parameters for your
applications
it's actually what
one of the things i really like about
working with panel is that
it
it makes it easy for you to make
reusable components right you can say
this is
this is a domain model
this could be anything it could be in
finance a black scholes model or
something like that here's just addition
we have two parameters a and b
and we have a resulting
function that was here it returns a
string but it could also
return matplotlib or whatever and panel
will like magically display it
and if we look at the code
param
so
all it is is really we have a class you
can think of it as a data class
we sprinkle in a little bit of
parametric param.parametrized define our
parameters
as a number and an integer and it says
it actually matters because now we have
validation a is a floating number and b
is an integer and if somebody inputs
something else
we will get validation errors
and one more powerful thing is that a
panel can use this
because we don't have to tell or think
about which widgets will use panel can
just magically
say
panel.param on this class and then we
get widgets and then we can place our
widgets inside a column together with
the resulting output function here
and we will get
a nice function like this so it means we
can build like libraries of domain
models independent of panel but we can
quickly visualize using panel
and panel of course is a part of
all of this
so you can build nice dashboards for
example
so again
let's take an
example app just to
to look at the code how does code like
this look so we could try this one
so this is this really illustrates often
what is the problem the problem is
really we have some code it has nothing
to do with data apps or panel or
anything here the example is somebody's
favorite plotting library is cbon
and they've made a function here with an
argument input argument a green color
and can we
and that's the function that they have
then they want to make it interactive
and that's where we can sprinkle in a
little bit of magic from panel
we always need to run pn.extension so
panel.extension
and we want to sprinkle in a drop down
or select widget here with a default
color value and some colors we can
choose from
and we want to make this function
interactive so we can bind that function
to the widget that's what you do here
and then we wrap it up in a nice
template
give the template some nice colors and
so on and
we put our select
widget in the sidebar and the
interactive function in the main
and then we run panel serve the name of
the script
and then we get a nice application that
we can
work with let us just check it out
yeah and this is the application that we
saw in the beginning
and for me at least it's not a lot of
code you have to
to do in in order to
to get something like this
so mark reminder that only one more
minute would be left
yeah thanks then i'll just wrap up
important for me is also that it just
works in your notebook and id so here
you have juvederm you have colab
you have vs code the interactive
environment
you have
vs code like python files
old grumpy coder like me i'm using this
and the good thing is whenever i save my
code it just updates over here
so that's pretty nice
and
yeah
one important kind of application is
really the cross filtering
that is pretty easy to make
an application like this
with panel
so you have nice cross filtering here
like that
and if we go back
then i will
finalize by saying you should check out
some of these nice resources so check
out the panel site
really nice
there's a getting started guide user
guide a reference gallery and so on you
should check out panel on github and
give it a star i think it deserves it
and yeah check out some of these other
links but if you are into like nice
interactive gifs gifs
check out the panel on twitter and
you'll see a lot of the different like
use cases for for panel illustrated by
the community
and
when you start out
you should also go to the
to the communist site
to get help
or just showcase what you can do so go
here and showcase what you can do
that's a nice sense inviting place to be
so uh thank you for your time
thanks a lot mark
um moving on i would now like to invite
silver
okay thanks everyone so uh let's talk
about vrola uh but before talking about
vola i'd like to talk about myself for a
little bit i hope that you all
understand my quaint french accent
uh so my name is silva corley i'm the
founder and ceo of quant stack so for
those who don't know quant stack it's a
paris and berlin-based
software
development company
we are
we essentially socialize in open source
software for
scientific computing the team comprises
about 10
core developers of jupiter and we're
also very active in the canada foreign
ecosystem
and as an open source developer i'm
personally very involved in the jupiter
project
and i'm one of the co-developers and
co-creators of voila
i also do a lot of volunteer work in the
community i'm a
one of the members of the board of
directors of non-focus and also
organized the pilot at paris meetup
last year i was the vice chair of
jupitercon
which was an online conference about
jupiter
in late 2020
so
before i get into voila uh let's
have a quick word about jupiter so
what's jupiter i think most people know
it but
jupiter more than just a notebook it's a
collection of interoperable tools for
interactive computing so it's really
meant to address
all of the stages of a
scientist workflows from the exploratory
phase of their work to the presentation
of their results
so it's a collection of open standards
more than a single application and a
single implementation for a concept like
the notebook
we actually
devised a well specified set of file
formats protocols so that anyone can
replace a component of the stack and
still interoperate with the rest of them
and most importantly it provides a the
notebook which is a document oriented
interface for discovery and
documentation and the notebook was
credited as being one of the first
implementations of the literate
computing paradigm by of the newt where
users actually
mix
narrative
content with executable code producing a
content that you know where you can
carry
uh a reasoning and you know have you
know
and the explanation of the program
alongside it and outside the source code
um so one
uh extension points of the jupiter
ecosystem is the jupiter widgets
ecosystem so what what jupiter widgets
are there are special objects
that have a an interactive
representation like a visual
presentation
in the jupiter notebook or in other
jupiter-based frontals
so initially it was really meant to
serve like as a small set of controls
that you could like put next to a plot
so that you can change some parameter
and see the impact of that parameter on
the outcome of your of your application
but actually from the start we built it
as a framework that you you can build
upon right and today there is a vibrant
ecosystem of custom widgets like ipygani
for 3d plotting so there is a nice
animation that the lower left corner of
ipagani with like some wave simulation
bq plot is a plotting library that was
built upon ipad widget's
ipad volume for volume rendering hyper
lift
for maps uh i think that the current
plotly uh
python
library actually is built upon ipad
widgets today
which was a huge word of confidence for
for the framework
uh ipad webrtc for video streaming we
got graph library there is like a really
vibrant ecosystem of such libraries
and that are really nicely interpreted
with each other because you can bind any
attribute of such a library with
the equivalent attribute of another
library and like make complex
applications using all of them together
so
the thing is
when you try to communicate with
notebooks
notebooks can be great for you know
working your audience through your
reasoning as you're trying to explain
how you build
a program like for example for class
but
it's not the best tool for all audiences
for example the one of the main issues
that people experience with notebooks is
that the most interesting content tends
to be in the end because that the stuff
that you are building in the notebook
and like the nice job that you want to
show to everyone is in the end and by
then you may have lost half of your
audience especially those who don't want
to see code
and
also if you really want to offer the
full interactivity of widgets to end
users
if you actually are using the netbook
you actually need to provide an
execution environment for the use of the
book so that they can move sliders and
interact with the camera so that's
another issue in terms of security and
finally if the audience that you want to
show your results to is not interested
in seeing the code but only the
narrative content and the features
then you're also in bad shape so some
people build some plugins to the network
to hide the code and to change the
layout but he didn't quite strike it
because he didn't resolve the
execution model and how we could just
you know securely share these
applications
and yeah so there were lots of
challenges
so essentially we need tools to look at
the book differently
so i wanted to point i'm going to send
the link after um to a blog post that we
recently published
on the jupiter blog by marina baranes
about looking at notebooks
with different glasses i think this was
a really nice blog post summarizing all
of you know the
current tooling that's available
for in the jupiter ecosystem
so now let's get into vola
so voila transform notebooks into
standalone applications so it can be
deployed securely to serve content
publicly
and it also provides a templating system
allowing authors to change the notebook
layout and turn notebooks into either
like interactive dashboards with a rich
layout or slideshows or just like a like
a one-page document
really looking like a notebook without
the input areas
so voila is also and this is really
something i want to emphasize
more than is like a separate tour from
the jupiter ecosystem vola is really a
jupiter story
we didn't build voila from the ground up
like on the side we reused existing
components from the gp2 ecosystem
so the notebook format the kernel
protocol the end becomes the template
and a lot of the improvements to the
underlying components over the past
couple of years were motivated by voila
so basically what i helped a lot improve
and be converted into all of the jupiter
stack
so
basically vola is very interoperable
with a jupiter ecosystem and one
important aspect of jupiter
uh that is key like it's one of the most
popular extension points is that jupiter
is agnostic to the programming language
you can
write you can use you know jupiter
kernels for c plus plus or lua
or many other languages and it's also
the case with voda and i think that roda
is probably unique in that way in that
it's a language agnostic dashboarding
tool you can make a dashboard in cpr
express using polar
so how do you use water here i have a
very simple python notebook with a bcup
figure
and you know it's interactive so there
is some you know zooming and panning
happening like that requires some
branches to the back end in this case
and you can try it locally very easily
by just typing voila and the name of the
notebook and it will spawn a small web
server on your machine
and you know just
serve your notebook
in an interactive fashion and you can
still do all of the things that you were
doing within the book even if it
requires some computation the back end
if you were doing i don't know some
analysis some pca whatever it may be
it works exactly the same as in the
notebook
and essentially so voila executes the
notebook and provides you with a kernel
but in order to share it securely the
way it works
is by changing and turning around the
execution model so in the case of voila
essentially the main difference is that
the frontend doesn't send any execution
request there is no arbitrary code
execution all it does is asking for a
specific notebook to be executed and
then the backend is going to serve the
rendered book progressively and keep the
kernel around for the user so that you
can
you know stay on the page and interact
with the widgets and the kernel will
only be shut down if you are idle for a
long period of time or if you close the
tab
uh so yeah i already insisted on
language agnosticism in this example i'm
showing a simplest plus
uh notebook that's using the
zeus clean kernel that's a
a simple space kernel based on the clean
simple space interpreter that was
developed at cern and you know this king
supports interactive widgets and here
i'm making a very simple application
where you can draw on an ipad leaflet
map and like get some you know c plus
plus call back and uh so if you are
really uh if you really have trouble
with python and you prefer cpus plus you
can write all of this and there is no
python even whatsoever in that dashboard
so you're safe
[Music]
so another important project of that
ecosystem is the voila gallery so it's a
vola gallery is actually a jupiter hub
extension
so it was announced by jeremy tulu on
the jupiter blog like some time ago and
but there there is a lot of development
in that space at the moment so we are
working on the binder base for the
gallery right now
so you can either deploy the gallery as
a binder extension or as a jupyter hub
extension
another extension point to voila is the
template system
so essentially
when rendering notebooks to the user
uh you can
actually apply some you know templating
system so that you can change the layout
or you know change the appearance of
of
like add some css or add like a header
footer anything you want like a logo for
a company
uh and
so we have a fairly generic templating
system that extends the one of nb
convert
and a collection of fairly actively
developed templates so one is volatile
beautify which is a 55.js based template
which is very i would say mobile
friendly
we have what a grid stack which is a
dashboard template where you can
rearrange uh widgets and in in a complex
fashion and voila reveal which is meant
to produce slideshows so i i didn't have
the
elegance
of mark to use a voila to make my
presentation about vola but maybe i
should have
um
and so what a great stack is this one i
was talking about which is
a means to
you know rearrange a notebook source in
with a complex layout the layout being
saved to the notebook metadata so that
when you open it with voila you get the
layout in rendered as expected
and we also have a visual editor for
grid stack templates that integrates
well with jupiter lab
and produces
such interactive dashboards
and this one
is a
dashboard about flavors of scotch that
was produced by ibm a long time ago for
another project that was called jupiter
dashboards and i actually used that one
that one dashboard for this example
because we decided to keep the same
layout format as the original project by
ibm so that we can render all of the
original dashboards from the dashboards
which is a deprecated project
what i reveal is this template for
turning notebooks into slideshows
what i beautify is a mobile-friendly
template that works really well uh in
combination with the ipad beautify
jupiter which is library
and now let's talk about the future so
in the next release of voila we are we
have
already merged actually and it's that we
are in the prerelease cycle for this
release
we enable the kernel hard pulling so
that um
voila dashboards rendered a render
immediately because we have a pool of
pre-rendered dashboards
ready for for the user
we're also working on enabling jupiter
light kernels to have pure web assembly
dashboards that execute fully in the
browser so if you're aware of jupiter if
you're not aware of gyptonium should
definitely check it out jupiter light is
a distribution of jupiter lab that works
entirely in the browser including the
norwegian also including python and it's
based on a python distribution compared
to webassembly called biodied so yeah
you should definitely google that
jupiter light
and
in the long term we'll be working on the
collaborative editing features for the
voda grid stack layout editors
and
also doing some experimentation about
having voila dashboards that enable some
collaboration collaboration features for
example you may have presence you may
see other users cursors that type of
stuff
and finally
uh it's not a one-man show there there
are lots of developers who contributed
to
to voila and uh i wanted to highlight
the names in the last slide
and that's it for me i hope i didn't go
over it seems not
great thanks a lot sylvain i would now
hand it over to each of you
hi everyone
um great to be here uh thank you so much
for your time i also want to point out
that marissa smith is here from
streamlit on our community team uh she
helped me prepare this presentation and
so uh hi marissa so uh yeah very happy
to be here um thank you so much jim for
inviting me um and i also want to say i
just really love the tone of this um
this whole presentation i uh
i uh you know i'm a former academic and
i love the python community and i love
this sort of academic feeling and and
seeing all the commonalities and
actually how all of these technologies
are built on very similar stacks so
very happy to be here um and especially
at pi data why because two years ago
streamlight was launched at pi data la
back when you could actually go
somewhere and see people uh and i i
showed uh this thing called streamlet um
and i also showed you guys a super janky
demo
which we're going to re-uh revisit a
little bit today um and uh and so since
then uh over the past two years uh it's
really been amazing uh streamlit has
taken off incredibly we've just launched
a whole bunch of really cool features uh
the response in the in the community has
been amazing and so it's kind of a
wonderful to come back here two years
later and especially on the eve of
another uh or right after i should say
another uh big milestone for us uh which
is the launch of one point l uh which is
basically
for us it means that uh the original
vision for which dreamlit could be we'll
get into that super easy way to turn
your python scientific scripts into apps
uh
has been the initial story has been uh
complete
and so uh i wanted to just share with
you guys a cool video uh which kind of
shows a little bit uh the journey that
we've been on since the original pi data
presentation of streamlight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cool so uh yeah a whole bunch of stuff
has happened uh uh over the past uh a
year and i want to share two years i
want to share that with you but i want
to take a step back and just um first of
all introduce myself and say hello so
i'm adrian i'm the co-founder and one of
the co-creators of streamlit the open
source project um and i have a
background actually as an academic so i
was a professor at carnegie mellon
university and then i went over to
google x and started helping with
self-driving cars and other crazy
scientific projects i went over to
zuke's and and helped them build
self-driving cars and then in 2018
founded streamlit and launched it in
2019
and i guess the point here is that um
i have seen a lot of
machine learning groups and been in a
lot of machine learning groups at the
time and over these years and um
and so i kind of created uh streamlets
uh the original idea was just to make it
really simple to
uh take a script that you were writing
and these could be uh data
transformations uh but it also could be
just sort of like the the scripts that
you have lying around in your computer
uh and the python script that you have
laughing around your computer and make
those visual in some way make the
ability to see how they're operating see
what's going on in all the matrices and
the numpy arrays and the data frames
and actually play with them
without having to go through a sort of
tedious um rewrite edit the code that's
part of the flow as well but you want a
way to
to be able to play with these things and
then share with them
share them with others and the result is
uh i think a tool that's been
really remarkably useful uh not only for
simple uh you know dashboarding style
use cases like the one that you see on
the left but also uh for just sort of
general python computation and in
particular machine learning which is my
background and i just want to call out
something i wanted to show you guys this
video because it's so cool but then i
was like there's probably some copyright
issues or something but anyway go to
project strike a pose uh on google
and uh it's a it's a it's a uh adobe
project that was released yesterday and
it's just so mind-bending uh here we
have a source image and then you can add
a target pose which is just an image and
then it generates a new image
which is uh of that source person but in
the target pose just completely
mind-blowing stuff uh really incredible
um the least impressive thing by far is
that it was created in streamlit and you
can actually see there that's a
streamline interface
and and actually i'm sort of very proud
of the fact that that's the least
impressive part of the demo and that's
kind of the whole part point of
streamlit uh which is that it sort of
fades into the background and lets you
just think about your the code itself
and so uh as uh jim invited me to give
this presentation
i was it actually really was a moment
for me to reflect about well what is it
that uh that i think makes streamline
special and why
uh is it you know the integration with
this or that library or is there
something deeper and i really came down
to two ideas that i want to share with
you guys
the first one is simplicity and the
second one is community and really
there's a lot more to both of these than
you might think
so i'll start off with uh simplicity and
give a quote from travis oliphant who's
uh uh
the father of numpy and scipy and i
think probably
as responsible as anybody for the
creation of the entire python data
ecosystem which we are all
uh thriving in and and hopefully working
together to grow and he had a super
interesting uh talk with lex fridman
another hero of mine a couple weeks ago
that i listened to and he said something
interesting about python that i think
really hit the nail on the head why is
python so special is it
because it's really amazing at
multithreading no
actually that he does a global
interpreter like and it's like kind of
terrible at multi-threading but somehow
it is turned into the most spoken
programming language in the world and
has this huge effect not only in the
data world but devops and education and
other places and what he said was python
let's you do
wait a minute i'm getting this wrong
python lets you do a lot without
demanding a lot of you
it lets you think
python lets you think
and that to me
uh that is really it when you're coding
in python and or when you're coding in
many other languages i feel like you're
thinking a lot about programming you're
thinking a lot about the abstractions
and somehow when you're coding in python
you're actually thinking about the
domain the whole time and that to me is
so special and that's really
the special thing about python that i
wanted to
carry into streamlet and so okay what is
streamlist for those of you who don't
know
uh it's a way to turn python scripts
into interactive
web apps
and um
it's super easy to get started uh you
can pip install streamlit and then you
can type stream at hello and it gets you
started from there
um and uh
and then uh it's based on very very
simple principles and i really liked
actually uh the way nicholas talked
about the simple principles underlying
uh underlying plotly dash
and and similarly for streamlit we try
to really minimize what you have to
think about so the first one is just
embrace python scripting so every
streamlit app is just a python script it
is native python you can in fact python
it
and it'll run as an ordinary script
and also you could streamlet run it and
then it'll run as something visual
the second one is treat widgets as
variables so we just want you to inject
wherever your script needs to sort of
change or branch you can just inject one
line of code you don't have to think
about uh sort of as an app developer you
think just as a python programmer as a
data script developer
and the final one is uh that we provide
some primitives that let you reuse code
over time this is a little bit the way
um a uh i'm forgetting the word but the
way of a cell works i think that's the
word in um in in jupiter
and uh it's super easy to add a whole
bunch of other interesting cool things
uh we've worked really hard like python
itself to make sure that stream that is
completely batteries included so out of
the box it works with all of the major
uh you know plotting libraries and again
i have to say you know listening to this
talk and listening to you guys all talk
uh it's very inspirational to see how
really this is actually just one
community and all these all these
technologies are interrelated so so so
deeply
um
and uh and uh finally you can really go
crazy and connect these primitives away
put together in a bunch of interesting
ways and i'll talk a little bit more
about that later uh over the past two
months we've uh released a whole bunch
of amazing fun things that make
streamline more beautiful uh that let
you
understand how to use it better
let developers and viewers interact with
their apps differently
and also i'm very excited to announce
that next tuesday we're going to be
launching streamlight cloud so actually
jim i really appreciated the way you
said you know all of these companies and
projects are supported financially in
different ways and that's a really
important part of the of the of the of
the story and i've really learned that
that's true you know streamlight started
off um actually as an open source
project it was not meant to be a company
and it became a company when we saw some
engineers that we're using it and we're
like oh wow there could be something
here
the open source project is very very
dear to my heart and um
and uh and so it's you know similar to
plotly the project itself is is is sort
of independent of the company and we
support it as a community project and
also we build a bunch of really cool
tools to let you uh uh share your
streamlit apps and deploy them and do
additional neat things on top but the
core streamline library is the same for
everyone
and so i wanted to show you guys a quick
demo of that
and so i must go back to the original uh
demo that i shared at street at pi data
two years ago this is it uh it looks a
little cooler now because we've added
some cool stuff
and so what i'm going to do is grab this
github repo
and i'm going to go over to share
dot streamlights dot io
actually you know this will be more fun
if we put them side by side so let's do
that
add to two
okay
so here we have github
uh and here we have uh streamlet and in
fact right now i'm in the uh streamlet
uh
workspace i'm going to switch over to my
own workspace here
okay so these are all my apps that i've
been working on i'm going to grab this
url that you see here on the left and
i'm going to
uh let's create a new app
and let's paste uh this url
we can do some additional fancy stuff
here which i won't go into and we can
deploy it uh this time it already had
been deployed so
so uh
so
it loaded really quickly otherwise it
has to build a container but it takes it
still quick and so here we have a you
know the the the same app
sorry to introduce adrian uh just a
reminder that we just have one more
minute
super cool stuff you can do here so we
can um
edit it for example in um in your source
repository so i'm going to change like
this
this uh select box
and turn it into a multi-select so how
would i do that
um
[Music]
so we go like this
come this out
and we'll commit this chain
and there it auto reloaded the app in
fact it kept the state which is like
really amazing so now this multi-select
is a uh
is a uh is a it allows you to program
the layout and super bowl okay um so i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm way behind schedule
on this talk as it turns out so i'm
gonna go really quickly
and i'm going to say
um
uh this is just a really cool technology
uh it's already being used in a ton of
companies it has security built in from
the beginning uh it lets you you can
work with all your single sign-on
providers uh we're working with the
large cloud providers to provide
streamlets to uh in in a very secure way
to connect your data sources so if
that's something interesting to you
should uh contact us um and so i think
that uh you know python uh lets you do a
lot without demanding a lot of you uh to
me that's really the the flip side of
simplicity is flow it's the ability to
build uh a lot of it not just one app
and make it a huge crazy project but
build a lot of things and we've seen
fortune 50 companies uh who have created
like a thousand streamlit apps
in production all running simultaneously
in the past year uh running various
aspects of their operations so that's
like super exciting the other thing i
want to tell you about in five seconds
is community uh this is uh really
important to us it's a huge part of what
makes it fun to work at streamlit and be
part of streamlift uh we really think
about who we are in the world these are
our values be kind um you know which is
not just be saccharine or or or or don't
have candor it means you know
means recognize the humanity and others
and i think that this actually plays out
throughout the entire uh throughout
everything that happens at extremely so
it's really fun to work here uh
you know uh we just had our off-site uh
our yearly op-site in colorado and these
are many of the people who work at
streamlit and uh it's just uh i want to
say shout out to all of them and say
thank you uh for for working with
streamlined every day it's really fun
working with all of you uh if you go to
the gallery you will see that um
uh there's a huge community of people
who are creating incredibly interesting
things
uh in streamlined and it's quite
inspirational and you can see all kinds
of uses and for machine learning and for
uh more traditional life supposed
dashboarding type applications i'm not
going to go into all of this stuff but
really cool uh you know if you go into
twitter and you search for streamlight
similarly to dash you'll see just
incredible amounts of energy i mean this
is it's just so so so cool
i don't can't even say this i think
we're you know we're still october 25th
that's three days ago and it just keeps
going and going okay um and uh oh custom
components really really cool so um
this is just like allowing people to to
create things uh you know and and and
extend the value that the thing of
streamlist uh here's a neat one that
lets you uh
have a
webcam component uh this is a demo you
can also we can start it right here uh
and uh there we go
uh and so uh
and you know stop ahead and change
things so yeah that's super cool to see
the community also building a lot of
interesting components for streamlet
um
and uh oh there's tons and tons of uh
you know contributors to streamlit and i
want to thank all of them over 180
streamlets
[Music]
adrian but if you don't
mind
oh okay uh i may have maybe have ten
more seconds to share one more demo
uh
uh and so finally i'll say hey you can
also there's a ton of just streamlined
on
uh
on github
um and that i think is is really neat uh
uh not only from the perspective of you
know 76 000 uh examples of imports
treatment as is t that's not that's
really neat not only from the
perspective of there's a huge code
examples to see how you can use stream
in different ways but
it actually um
uh
it's so there's so much streamlet on uh
online that in fact um over half the
fortune 50 is a streamlit there's oh
there's a cool book about streamlet
by a bias by a data scientist but anyway
i'll get to the whole point here which
is that there's so much streamlined on
github at this point uh that now
uh ai's have learned to speak
streamlight automatically so this is a
really mind-bending demo where someone
says an app which shows price for google
stock and then they say from stream
imports limited sst import yahoo finance
and this entire app is written from
scratch using codecs uh
uh and and generates a working streamlit
app that shows google stock price really
this is something that you can try
yourselves this is really really
stunning so i will pause there i will
end there and say that the flip side of
community is power we think that all
these things come together in a really
interesting way in streamlit and so
thank you so much for your time and uh
sorry for going it over and uh looking
forward to the discussion
thanks a lot for all the cool stuff
adrian um now going back again to james
for the discussion topics
uh all right so that that concludes the
portion of this workshop where everyone
gets to present their own case for their
own library why it's interesting and
exciting and all of them are clearly
interesting and exciting
but this is the this last portion of it
is really the unique feature of this
workshop where you get to hear what each
library thinks about each other and all
the other libraries and how they relate
to each other
um and to start that off i'd like each
of the library authors to think of one
good and nice thing to say about the
another library
or all the other libraries if you want
um but just something to point out that
is a strength of one of the other other
libraries something that um that that
other library uh does well
and so in let me see what order we were
going this order so probably
uh go backwards order this time adrian
uh you could have maybe uh two minutes
to say uh that sort of thing
a two minutes okay cool uh yeah well i
mean there's there's first of all thank
you for setting this up this way jim
it's really cool and i do think that
like the larger picture of the python
data ecosystem being something that
we're all part of and trying to grow and
it's strong is i just love that framing
so um i mean we're where to start uh you
know uh voila i think is a very
beautiful way of connecting uh
uh extending the story of jupiter into
uh into this dashboarding framework and
of really connecting that story uh and
you know it i think it makes a lot of
sense if you're working in a jupiter
notebook to to create things and voila i
also just want to say you know obviously
jupiter itself is is basically a
stunning uh advancement in scientific
community in computing and we we
probably all wouldn't be here if not for
jupiter so uh shout out to that
community and and the jupiter folks um
you know uh very cool uh
i guess i'll say something about all of
them a very cool um
uh uh um instagram liking all the news
uh plotly dash uh demo uh where you know
the reactivity uh going back to python
is is really uh is really stunning and i
think that the the sort of basic set of
abstractions that you guys have
put together make a lot of sense and
hold well together
and then finally
for panel uh i think you know obviously
a great deal of work has gone into
visualizing large data sets and uh and
also uh creating real-time dashboards
which i don't think you showed mark but
it's something that's really neat about
panels so uh you know all the yeah i'm
struck in many ways by the commonalities
among these projects behind
there okay thank you very much um
uh sylvain
hey um
yeah so i i don't i didn't really know
stream it so well but i think this demo
of by adrian was absolutely stunning so
i um
every time i've seen examples of
streamlight it seemed and it's obviously
so polished and you know we'll finish
that you know it's it's it seems to be a
very impressive
framework
uh
regarding dash i think we've looked a
lot into dash recently uh specifically
with respect to scalability and you know
because they have a so different like
execution model from voila and
and we were like trying to think of you
know what we could you know
do to be closer to dash's uh scalability
so
that's definitely and like we're
obviously good friends with the partly
folks and who are building upon ipad
widgets for for the library as well so
uh clearly yeah i would say dash's
scalability is
what where what is really striking
and um regarding panel so it's really
funny because i think the first panel
released was announced at the same
jupiter community workshop as voila
so philip was attending and we both
announced the
first release in the same in the same at
the same event
and uh and so yeah i mean panel is sort
of the natural
uh you know
top layer on top of
you know the whole of this framework and
like all of that stack and so it makes a
lot of sense for building applications
with with you know with large amounts of
data so
yeah
that's it
all right thank you um mark
yes thanks
so there's a lot of good things to say
but if i should say one thing
so for for streamlit it's really if you
have one function and you want to make
it interactive it's really easy with
streamlit
and for walla
well wallet just provides what the
jupiter uses they they need and crave
and and so on it it really provides
something for that community that fits
really well in there and then i would
say for
for a dash well dash really it speaks
the language language of enterprise you
could say and it's really good at that
all right and uh nicholas
uh thanks everyone um yeah i love this
part uh i so so streamlined i just think
that the developer extreme experience of
writing a stream laid out app is just
lovely like it's so fluent um and the
the automated caching uh mechanism is
great and something i'm very jealous of
uh so you guys have done an incredible
job of sort of like bridging that gap
um
for voila i actually think it's it's
sort of similar the thing i really love
about voila
is um
if you came to my talk earlier today i
really care a lot about data scientists
being able to build their own tools
really quickly uh data scientists spend
a lot of their time in jupiter um and i
just love the fact that you're just like
in jupiter and then
and then you're you're in voila um so
that that that like no extra step aspect
of it uh really really seals the deal
for me and i i love voila for that um
and and the fact that it's um you know
uh
like like totally open source um
uh and part of the ecosystem um anyway
it's great um and panel i i'm always
very impressed with the uh the sort of
scope of vision and sort of unifying
concepts uh that that the hall of face
community comes out with um you know to
have the whole like there's some
beautiful diagrams on their website of
like kind of the vision of uh everything
to do with with computation and viz uh
and and hall of is and g plot and how
they connect to every other part of the
of the ecosystem um and uh and that's
that's just like a real strength uh of
uh of what panel and hallows do so um
you know thank you all for for
everything that you do for this
community um and it's something that i
look i like kind of look over the fence
sometimes at other communities and have
this kind of monoculture of everyone
uses the one library
and people think that we here in python
are a little like fragmented and weird
and people can't just decide but this is
a huge strength of our communities that
we have so many amazing options and
people working together and
interoperating thanks
very cool
okay
thank you all those are really
insightful comments and i'm actually
going to read the uh listen to the
recording later and kind of uh think
about each one of them those are those
are really helpful thanks everybody
um i collected some votes for discussion
topics from the um slack channel and
there were two votes each for numbers
three and four so let's go ahead and
start with those um
number three uh if each author could
sort of just say
very succinctly
uh what does your library offer so for
exporting to a standalone html page that
you could send in an email or
provide to somebody who doesn't have
python running
so uh go back to the original order so
uh nicholas
uh good question so any given uh
certainly plotly figure can be exported
to html uh a dash application
uh does not does not have a sort of
obvious way of doing that
within dash enterprise is possible to
export to pdf pretty easily
but that's uh that's something where we
don't um
sort of architecture a little bit
challenging the main purpose of dash is
to connect the ui to a python function
so without the python piece there's not
a whole lot that we can do
okay thanks uh mark
yeah
so i think this is where panel has
something unique you can think about
video recording actually that's what
panel can do so if you have an
interactive application running on a
server then it can actually like run
through all the combinations of sliders
or widgets or something like like that
at least to a limit and sort of record
the application and then you have a
static
html application you can share with a
colleague by an email or slack or
something like that
well
so then
yeah so the answer for vola is that for
this purpose we use the auditors from
the jupiter stack and specifically nb
convert the latest release of the
convert includes the tour called deja vu
which is another you know part of my
plot to
force americans to type accents
and
so deja vu turns
uh notebooks into html or pdfs through a
headless browser and can apply it has
the same basic and default options as
voila and it can apply for the templates
so if you type deja vu in notebook or if
you use the like the nd convert endpoint
in jupyter lab you get the pdf
corresponding to your dashboard or html
depending on what you want
[Music]
cool
adrian uh so uh so streamlit doesn't
have an export html feature uh we
actually originally did uh but uh we we
got rid of it and really focused on um
on making stream that apps extremely
shareable so the example that i showed
you uh was you click to deploy and then
uh this url is given to you that you can
share anywhere in the world
and streamline cloud which is coming out
next tuesday it's been in beta with
about 600 companies uh is about making
that possible inside of organizations so
we
really focus on uh creating interactive
artifacts and then we want to make it a
really beautiful shareable experience to
pass those artifacts around securely in
an organization or with the whole world
all right well thanks for that sort of
segue into number four uh so maybe uh
just one little quick uh distinction
between number four and five if each of
you could talk about four but compared
to five the difference between deploying
one of your apps for all the world to
see or deploying behind a firewall
i'll just keep rotating i guess um so uh
dash is built on flask uh flask is
pretty easy to deploy uh folks deploy uh
dash applications publicly on heroku all
the time uh you can do it for i believe
free or small dollar amounts um we do
not today have a uh polly hosted kind of
shiny apps type thing or uh or
streamlight share system although we're
thinking about it um
beyond heroku you can deploy it on
basically you know any of the recipes
that exist to deploy a flask app on like
digitalocean or anything else
that broadly holds for internal systems
as well you can deploy a dash
application
anywhere you like and of course for
internal systems we love it if you if
you license dash enterprise to do that
which is a whole set of tools
that allow you to control who can who
can access your dash apps so you can use
that both publicly or internally if you
want although the majority of our
customers
do so in turn
so yeah again you can deploy almost
anywhere but not on python anywhere
because they don't support web sockets
and one of the unique things about panel
is actually that you don't have to buy
an enterprise subscription or whatever
to get authentication it's built into
pen
yeah so you
voila really uses the jupyter stack
for that purpose as well so we document
deploying voda specifically
on top of a running jupyter hub instance
or on a heroku or even a binder
so if you need some specific single
sign-on
plugin you can't just use the
corresponding jupiter plugin
okay and adrian
uh sorry are we i'm just gonna perhaps
combine four and five so
okay cool so um yeah so streamlit has a
public uh sharing uh uh service called
shared.streamlet.io
um we've just uh really uh lifted the
cap on the number of public apps that
you can share used to be three now it's
infinity um that's because we had
actually the the head of uh of uh uh
platform development at heroku joined
stream at a year and a half ago and has
helped us really build a scalable system
for sharing apps so that's pretty
exciting um right now there are over 30
000 apps shared and streamlined apps are
going to be viewed 1.5 million times
this quarter so we're really excited
about that uh and then um
the the same technology is used uh in
streamlight cloud to allow companies to
securely share apps with one another um
we have a bunch of additional technology
that lets you do secure connection to
data sources and so forth it is a sas
service so that is a the security model
that we offer um in addition uh yeah
streamlight can be deployed uh you know
in heroku and all these other things if
you go to our docs we have we encourage
that usage we show you how to put it on
gcp on amazon on heroku on wherever
digital ocean etc
and then you know a lot of
big companies
have actually created their own
streamlet uh uh basically
systems inside uh the company so uh you
know famously uh uber famously for us
uber created uh added stream up to their
data science workbench which is a lot
you know allows all uh employees to to
deploy streamlit apps and so
um what we
do is um you know for large companies
like that at present streamless sharing
is usually not the right solution for
security reasons and then we help them
create their own streamline deploy
so that's the internal to their uh vpc
or on-prem
okay thank you very much
all right we've got um
two more that have about two votes
that's seven and twenty so um
seven how much do you have to know web
technologies javascript or html
and i guess if you want you can contrast
it with number nine which is that if you
do know these things how easily can you
um
can you customize and get into the
nitty-gritty so maybe go back and forth
between those two do you have to know
and can you use it if you do know
so again let's just keep the same order
it makes it so much easier so uh
nicholas
yeah sure thing so um given the dash is
based on on react uh you can use any
react component that exists been wrapped
in dash um
do you you don't have to know any
javascript uh to use to use dash
components if you do know javascript you
can either build your own components or
wrap existing components
um do you need to know html and css you
don't need to you can use a component
suite like dash bootstrap components
that lets you kind of work at a slightly
higher level
if you have a preferred sort of
framework for doing stuff you can either
find or build
a set of components that use it
but if you do know html and css
you can you can use you know html.div
and p and span and all the css stuff you
want uh so we really do try and give you
access to the to the full um
the full breadth of the stack um
and and you know i showed a bunch of
different apps that really did have
quite different looks and feels um and
and most of those apps actually that i
showed were uh were built by uh not by
polly employees like these are apps that
that you know folks have successfully
and happily built so um we like we like
the balance that we're striking there
thank you
um mark
yes
so as a beginner you don't need to know
anything about javascript html or css
for yeah that's that's what we want to
provide with panel
but
we all we also want you to not meet dead
ends so if you have friend friends
colleagues some something like that you
can call in
rockstar front end developer then you
can use javascript html and css to build
custom components
with javascript or typescript react web
components whatever
okay thanks
so bad
yeah uh you don't need to do any
javascript or css or html to write a
voila
notebook because you just need to know
how to make a notebook
however if you do
then you can create new jupyter widgets
very easily so which are the equivalent
of other components i would say
and
another thing that you can do if you are
proficient in short-term development is
create a new voila template for example
you could make a template for your
company that has the label for companies
some boilerplate
uh you know legally at the bottom that
type of stuff
uh adrian
uh yeah so uh similar story uh you don't
need to know extremely you don't need to
know html and css
we try to make uh sort of the basic
components that you'd want to use to
make an app available and super easy to
use um that's part of the point uh you
can use uh
we are also based on react uh so that's
the simplest uh uh thing to use but we
also allow custom components to iframe
and anything they want and that allows
you to use view uh people have used elm
um to create components for streamlight
and that's how for example the webcam
components i showed you earlier and of
course uh was created and of course you
know this uh streamless emphasis on
community means that we also uh really
have an active community around building
components and sharing uh other kinds of
uh bits of snippets of of code online
and so if you go to shimmer.ios
components uh you can see lots of
examples of um of interesting components
also mark runs awesome streamlight which
is a great way to find out other cool
examples of stream that use and
components
very cool okay so
looks like 20 has a lot of lists uh okay
applications this is uh suggested by
nicholas actually so nicholas
application that library x is not
suitable for
yeah um
so so it's painful to talk about this no
um so you know we would like dash to be
to be uh really suitable for for
everything else for everything uh i
would say that that where dash is
probably weakest right now and this
maybe connects to 12 here is sort of the
the experience of sort of starting in a
notebook and moving to an app um and so
if you if you have something built in a
notebook with ipi widgets um
and you've built yourself a small tool
and you want to kind of like switch to
or upgrade to being to building a a
richer app um
and you want to do so with dash that's
that's more difficult uh and i would say
the sort of activation energy to kind of
jump out of your your notebook flow if
that's where you're at uh to to start
building in a dash app is probably the
the biggest impediment to using dash
right now um so so i would say it's not
used it's not so suitable for building
yourself like a one-off little tool uh
when you're when you're in your notebook
flow
oh mark
sorry i didn't hear the question what is
panel not really suitable for compared
to these other tools
yeah so sometimes people they ask me
should i build a sas application and
earn money on it and have a lot of
customers and that's not really what
it's for it's like for super user tools
inside an enterprise inside a university
inside a
an organization i would say
[Music]
okay
uh silver
yeah i think uh the b sensor also
applies to to voila uh what are really
only skills as much as you can provide
compute environments for each user
and
you have very you know it's a it's it's
an embarrassingly powerful problem so
you can certainly scan it up you know by
spawning more
parts in the kubernetes cluster that
type of stuff but
um
it's really the opposite model to dash
which is like completely stateless and
it's really based on a normal you know
web server that you can you know
uh i guess put behind the load balancer
or the type of stuff so really there
there is a limit to the scale that you
can you know deploy dashboards
oh and adrian
um
uh
yeah so
uh there's there's many ways of
answering this question um
uh i i think one way that i was just
thinking of is um if you if you go to uh
roadmap.streamlight.io or tradason.org
roadmap uh you can see sort of all the
things that we're working on and in many
ways that's kind of um a picture of
where we'd like the uh the the
the the app to go um and so i'm just
looking at this right now we're working
on um workspace invitations multi-page
apps custom subdomains perhaps um
ability to set up third-party analytics
uh st.user which is the ability to sort
of tie user identity into various
aspects of your app sd.database a tiny
no-sql database for every app and stream
in the cloud by the way this is none of
this is secret you can see this all
online a drawable canvas widget uh
anchors everywhere tabs container pop-up
containers um so
lots and lots of cool things coming down
the line and each one of the the lack of
each one of those is is certainly uh
painful to us
but we're excited to be bringing them to
you all in the coming months
okay thank you um it looks like there
was confusion about between 11 and 12
on the chat i see but in any case i
think 12 has been covered by something
by each of the uh discussions so how
about number 11 some of the votes for 12
or apparently for number 11. so how good
is your app framework at
creating complex apps that have
multi-page uh or involved
some form of state particularly state
between multiple pages that sort of
thing
so uh nicholas
yeah um so i think it's really important
to to highlight with dash so we have a
stateless architecture
and that is stateless sort of from the
point of view of the server that's the
kind of very low level technical detail
but um dash is actually extremely well
suited to building sort of very complex
um complex applications so multi-page is
pretty easy there's a dash component for
the the location people do this all the
time um
that one uh video that i showed like two
seconds of i encourage people to watch
it because it's pretty impressive so
folks are building uh quite powerful you
know multi-stage tools uh out of dash
where you know either you upload a file
you run some process you used to give
some more user input drag things around
um uh so so dash is actually pretty good
at that um and the complexity doesn't
scale too badly like it's not your app
doesn't like explode in complexity when
you when you build this the the reactive
model uh the stateless sort of pure
functional model scales really really
well with that you can break your app up
into little little files have separate
little functions unit test them and
decorate them um and so that's i feel
like one of the real strengths of dash
cool no
yeah so i feel like multi-page apps
that's really a strength of panel it's
really coming out of you can just have
individual files each of them are an app
and then you serve them up and they're
sort of connected so that's really a
strength
and then you can say the architecture of
yeah panel
and streamlet and walla is the opposite
of dashrite it's it has state
for panel we have session state so the
individual user can have like that
the state of a data frame or something
or a plot
but you can also share state across
sessions so if you have like an
you're loading expensive data or
something you can you can do it once and
then you can share it with across users
cool
yeah sorry i was looking for the unmute
button so
yeah voira is a stage four application
so it depends on what the complexity is
i would say
if you have a very complex model in the
backend that requires a lot of data you
can certainly do that with with voda
easily
then in terms of the complexity of the
front end like multi-page whatever it
all is limited by the widget framework
that you decide to use you could use
like advanced ones like apple beautify
and which are mobile friendly if you
just use the basic app i will just
control you can only go so far you know
because you
you know
then in order to make complex layouts
you need to start
uh using you know
nested widgets and
edge boxes and v boxes which can you
know
only go so far when you know if you
really want to have something like a
i don't know a neutral nuclear plant
control panel that's that may not be the
best one so then i think you need to use
it like a more of
a really good framework to build this
kind of application
adrian
um
so uh yeah
our customers do create very complex
multi-page apps in streamlit uh they
also create stateful apps as described
in a number of ways we took a very long
time to release
our own first party state
abstractions in streamlit and the reason
is because
i guess
perhaps to a fault we're obsessed with
uh just the simplicity of the of the ui
and and the uh the developer experience
uh we haven't yet released a first-party
way of creating multi-page apps um
they're certainly creatable i'm looking
at our own internal app dashboard right
now which is a multi-page app and we
have uh
we can point to many examples of big
companies uh but we're working on trying
to
really bring an api that we think
expresses that idea of multi-page apps
and also sort of multi-function
computation
in a way that's super
easy for the developer and just as
importantly super understandable and
consumable for the viewer
very cool okay it looks like the next
most common is 14 rendering large data
sets necklace
yeah um
i would say that that sort of just works
like dash doesn't really have a whole
lot to say about about the size of the
data that you're that you're running uh
it's mostly kind of the conduit for that
so um people use uh people use dash to
front extremely large data sets you know
uh connecting to
upstream servers like i don't know
snowflake databricks rapids um
desk and so on
and we interoperate really well with um
with stuff like data shader and
holoviews so there's not really anything
in the way of you using the usual the
usual uh python suspects um i linked to
that one app that has uh you know a data
shader overlay on a map and a desk back
end um at the nvidia
gtc keynote a couple of years ago a year
ago it's been a long pandemic
they talked about using uh using rapids
and dash uh to sort of track real-time
covert infection data um
so yeah
dash is sort of just python and you can
use all the usual suspects for large
data sets
sounds good mark
yeah
so i would say panel and holovis is
really driving the big data
visualizations via data shader and other
stuff
so yes you can and especially also think
that actually the that you have state in
your application makes it sort of easier
to make interactive
big data visualizations
okay so that
yeah once again i think i'll give the
same answer it's very orthogonal to
voila the size of the data is really
eternal true to
to how voila works for that has been
used in combination with uh troll such a
surveys of vex for example for actually
doing some data destination for plotting
and whatnot and just like you can do in
the notebook
cool all right adrian
um
i i'll i'll be a little bit uh
controversial and say that
while i do think that the size of the
data
sources are in a sense orthogonal to
these frameworks um
i it's
it's it's easy to say
you know you can't necessarily hold a
you know
paradight data frame in memory for
example uh and it's easy to say oh well
it's python it's all programmable so
therefore it all works for large data
frames because you can always do
something in python that fixes that i
think that's true and that's certainly
true of streamlined as well uh but uh
you know in terms of uh built-in basic
primitives to do those kinds of things
uh you know uh streamlet uh and and
actually i think many of these other
frameworks with perhaps the exception of
panel i'm not sure how that works uh are
are actually really not designed for
giant data sets and they have to be sort
of wired together with uh on top of
spark or other things in order to make
that possible uh that's certainly true
with streamlined as well um i i would
also say that a a minor but kind of cool
thing about streamlight is that because
it the the basic framework is that
you're running a um
a script and scripts themselves are
designed to work on you know arbitrarily
long computation uh
streamlight was really designed to make
it possible to create uh progress bars
and other kinds of things that sort of
show you the the progress of a long
computation as it's happening um and
that's something that uh that's one way
and perhaps a slightly non-trivial way
in which we make it slightly easier to
work with large data sets
okay looks like we have time for one
more question and then and maybe a last
statement from each of the libraries
about uh things that you've learned so
um well why don't you go ahead and
combine them because number 19 is the
next one in votes and it's intended
mainline application for x like what is
the prototypical reason somebody would
use this library and so if each of the
um participants could have let's say we
have seven minutes so two minutes a
piece uh to talk about that for each for
your library what is this really for and
anything else you want to throw in in
that two minutes
uh nicholas go
yeah for sure there's a question about
accessibility which i think is really
important so i'll i'll spend 30 seconds
on it so accessibility uh in terms of
sort of keyboard navigation um and and
aria tags and readability um is
something that is primarily driven by
the by the component layer and the front
end layer
so i will say that within dash
our built-in components are not
particularly accessible and it's
something that we'd like to work on and
we'd left some help with
and that
custom components that are built sort of
the accessibility thereof
depends on depends on the custom
component so that's not something that
that we do an amazing job at but we
would we would love to learn more about
how to do that
um
the intended main line application for
dash i would say is basically um you
know i kind of think about it as the
last mile in some ways to uh to data
science projects is to is to
provide a user interface and a way for
humans to connect with data and models
um so be that you know kind of a
read-only interface to sort of do data
exploration or
a sort of bridge to connect the work of
data scientists and non-data scientists
you know people who have access to
python code
and you know sort of giving their output
or bringing people in who who have
expertise about a particular domain um
uh to to bear into it to sort of work
with python code so that's that's sort
of the the high-level main line
application for uh for dash um
and um
by way of closing like this has been a
really fun session it's been really nice
to have everyone sort of side by side
and be able to kind of let everyone
uh speak for themselves so thank you
thank you mark
yeah so the intended or mainline
application for panel is probably like
domain applications just as before like
if you are a scientist you want to make
something for yourself something for
your colleague something for your
stakeholders your manager
maybe something for a customer i also
see
people coming out of cern working with
big data making aviation tracking
applications or stuff like that so yes
thanks so much
yeah
i would say that
the main
use case for vola is if you have for
example a team of data scientists who
are using jupiter and know how to make
nice jupiter notebooks they don't have
to run anything new they can just turn
these notebooks into
voila dashboards
if they want to apply a template with
the company you know
visual identity and you can easily you
know share
search volatile dashboards with the
users of a jupiter hub
deployment so this is you know really
you don't need to know that you're
making a dashboard in order to make the
dashboard so that's really the main
thing and in the future i mean it's
going to be even easier jupiter is
really making strides in with respect to
social features uh like collaborative
editing just turned into jupiter lab and
now we are going to have like an
experience that's really closer to like
google docs and that type of stuff and
within that framework where you can
really have like collaborative
um
environments uh i think that voda is
going to become even more
you know easy to use and easy to uh like
an even better tool for sharing
information within a team or a company
cool thanks
uh adrian
um uh similar to to what uh the others
have said here you know uh streamlet is
a superpower which lets data scientists
um build apps without uh needing to know
really anything beyond the python stack
i think the thing that where we really
shine and where we've really put a lot
of focus in and it's just sort of a
thread through all the demos i showed
you was we really wanted to make it
possible to create apps so quickly and
to iterate that on them so quickly this
is something that and therefore to not
view apps as a sort of rarified thing
that you do every now and then but
rather as a sort of byproduct of the
data science workflow that you just have
a thousand apps why not ten thousand
apps uh and so uh that's something that
we both are seeing internally at
streamlit actually um you know there's a
problem with this data source oh here's
an app that lets you introspect that
data source and find all of the mistakes
and i just created it in half an hour
and i just shared it with you and by the
way by the end of the day we're not
going to need it anymore the app's gone
um that's just super cool and uh and and
then make them extremely shareable and
extremely usable by others inside of the
organization and so uh yeah we are
seeing with a big automaker you know for
the first year it was
you know five apps and then it was 30
apps and now it's a thousand dollars and
so that that sort of
suddenly cambrian explosion of building
apps really quickly iterating on them
super quickly fixing the code during the
meeting and having it update live that's
what we're really focused on
very cool
okay well i'd really like to thank all
of the uh panelists for
such insightful comments about your own
libraries and everyone else's that was
really helpful and thank you to the
audience for the
questions that you uh piped in there and
for your
supportive comments in the chat that's
been really helpful and thank you to the
moderator and to pi data in general for
hosting this and
setting this all up
it's been a great experience thank you
thank you so much thanks james
thank you thank you
thank you everyone